The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: So
problems set 5 was due now.
And problem set 6
is due next week.
It will be posted later today.
Welcome to the parents.
We will have clickers too.
Thank you for coming.
So today's topic,
we're continuing
with chemical equilibrium.
And depending on when
the clickers come,
the fun video may be at
the top of the lecture.
But before that, today is going
to be a clicker competition.
And hopefully, for the
parents in the room,
your child has told you what
these clicker competitions are.
The parents will be in
their own recitation.
If you win, I think you have to
come back next week for snacks
at recitation.
So we'll explain that.
But some recitations have been
doing very well in the clicker
competition, but
they have not won.
So I just want to share with
you another extra-credit clicker
assignment.
And this extra-credit
clicker assignment
is something you can do this
weekend with your parents.
So again this is optional.
This is to win for your
recitation extra-credit points
to get into the championship
at the end of the semester
to win the geeky T-shirt.
The geeky T-shirt is itself a
prize, or a extra-credit thing
to get in.
OK.
So in class, I have been
showing science videos.
And these are the stars
of the science videos.
They're MIT undergrads,
graduate students, post-docs,
and faculty.
And they've been talking about
how they use basic chemical
principles in their
research and how
that research is
important for addressing
a real-world problem.
So the extra credit
assignment is
that each of these
individuals also
has a two to-- I think
the longest one is about--
five-minute personal video.
And so the extra
credit assignment
is to watch one or all,
as many as you want,
of these personal
videos, and then
send Allena an e-mail
with your recitation
number in the subject line
saying one thing that surprised
you in a personal
video or one thing
to which you could
really relate,
that someone said in
their personal video.
So it can just be
one or two sentences.
It doesn't have to be long.
When I gave this
assignment before,
I'll give you a little help on
where you might want to start.
We had the most comments
about Ben's personal video
and Samuel's personal video.
And some people also commented
on my personal video.
So these are personal
videos that kind of
tell people's path to science
or people's path to chemistry.
So
I thought this might
be a fun thing to do.
It's available online here.
You can watch some of these-
again, two-to-five-minutes--
with your parents.
And that might also help your
parents understand a little
about the people
who are here at MIT.
So this is something,
and it's due November 3.
But I thought it
might be a fun thing
to do homework with their
parents on visiting weekend.
That's an awesome
thing to be able to do.
All right.
So clicker competition.
Recitations 7-- Dan
must unseat him.
Here's one that parents
might know the answer to.
We'll see.
And again, you can share.
But remember, your parents
are competing against you.
All right.
Let's just try 10 more seconds.
Very good.
So that's the answer.
So that was yesterday.
And so this, every year,
it's National Chemistry Week
on the week of Mole Day.
So this is national
chemistry week.
So if I can get most of
the way through lecture,
I'm going to share
with you a fun
video at the end that celebrates
national chemistry week.
So hopefully we'll get there.
But first, let's
talk a little bit
about chemical equilibrium,
the subject for today.
So chemical equilibrium--
it's all about staying calm.
So we want the rate in to
be equal to the rate out.
We like to be at this
equilibrium place.
But sometimes, often, all the
time-- frankly, all the time,
stress is applied to our
equilibrium situation.
And systems must respond in such
a way to alleviate that stress.
So Le Chatelier's
principle suggests
that, when a stress is
applied to the system,
the system will respond in such
a way to minimize the stress.
Again, this is about keeping
calm, minimizing stress.
And if you think about what
direction the reaction will
go to minimize the
stress, you can predict
the direction of the reaction.
So today, we're going to talk
about some of the stresses
to the system.
Last time, we talked
about adding and removing
reactants and products.
This time, we're going
to talk about gases.
And we're going to talk
about changing the volume.
That's our first
stress to the system.
So if you decrease the
volume of a gaseous system,
it will cause an increase
in the total pressure.
And we know this from
the ideal gas law
and other relationships also
between pressure and volume.
So the ideal gas
law is something
most MIT students are
familiar with, because it
is, in fact, the T in MIT.
So PV equals nRT.
where P is pressure, V is
volume, T is temperature,
n is the number of
moles of that ideal gas,
and R is our ideal gas constant.
So this relates
pressure to volume
at a constant temperature
and relates pressure, volume,
and temperature and also
number of moles to reach other.
So this is a very
important expression,
and we won't actually be talking
very much about the ideal gas
law.
But you need it in this
unit, because in this unit,
we're thinking about stresses
to equilibrium situations
and how reactions
are going to respond.
So if you decrease the
volume of a gaseous system,
causing an increase
in total pressure,
the system's going to respond in
such way to minimize the stress
or decrease the total pressure.
And so Le Chatelier's
principle would
predict that, if
possible, the system's
going to respond in such a way
to reduce that total pressure.
So you increase the pressure,
reduce the pressure.
Minimize the stress.
So let's look at a reaction
of a gas to another gas.
So here we have the
molecules of gas P2
going to one molecule of P4.
And if we had a container
with a particular volume
and we compress that volume, the
reaction that is at equilibrium
is going to respond.
And here, a decrease
in volume is
going to shift the
reaction toward product.
So why is this?
Why is it going to
shift it toward product?
And it's because, for
every two molecules of P2
that are consumed, only one
molecule of P4 is formed.
And thus, the shift toward
product, shift toward P4,
is going to reduce the
total pressure, because you
have fewer molecules of gas.
So each of them is a little bit
happier in this now decreased
Volume
So you can also just think
about what direction,
where are the moles, and
how this is shifting.
But you can also think about
this in terms of Q and K,
and I highly recommend this.
I'm a big fan of thinking about
the relationship between Q
and K. So let's
think about this now.
Let's just suppose
that the volume
is decreased by a factor of 2.
So we were at equilibrium.
Q was equal to K. K
is the equilibrium
constant, or the reaction
quotient, at equilibrium.
But now, we have
changed the volume by 2.
So we can think about
what has happened to Q.
So Q is products over
reactants at any time point.
Product is the partial
pressure of gas P4--
that's our product--
over the partial pressure
of the reactants, the
partial pressure of P2 gas.
But there are two
of them, so we have
to remember the stoichiometry
of the reaction.
So both of these are affected.
But because of the
stoichiometry of the reaction,
Q is now a half.
So Q has changed.
We have decreased
Q by a factor of 2.
So Q is now less than K. So
tell me what happens to delta G
in this situation.
Let's try just 10 more seconds.
Yep.
So it is a negative value,
and let's take a look at why.
So delta G is negative.
And we recall this relationship
that delta G RT natural log
of Q over K. So when
Q is less than K,
you get a negative
value for delta G.
And when you have a
negative value for delta G,
the reaction goes in
the forward direction.
So a negative value
for delta G means
it's spontaneous in
the forward direction.
The forward direction
is toward products.
And this will happen
until Q equals K again.
So you can think about
this based on the equation.
Always ask yourself,
this Q changing?
Is Q less than K
or greater than K?
And that'll predict
the direction to which
the reaction will switch.
So it's going to go in
the forward direction
if delta G is negative.
All right.
Now let's increase the
volume and think about what
happens in the container.
So we have a container here.
We increase the volume.
So now, we're going to
shift to the reaction
toward our reactants.
So the increase
in volume is going
to lower that total pressure.
And we can think
about this switch.
We have one molecule
of P4 on the products,
two molecules of P2 here.
So for every one
molecule consumed
in the backward direction, two
molecules of P2 are formed.
So the shift will
compensate for this change,
and we're going to increase
the delta pressure, which
was decreased before, by
this increase in volume.
So again, you're
shifting it in such a way
to minimize the stress.
Even if the stress is
a decrease in pressure,
you want to be back at
your equilibrium place.
So you'll shift to then
increase the total pressure just
to compensate in any
way, minimize the stress.
Whatever the stress is,
you want to minimize it.
All right.
Let's do something
slightly trickier.
Let's add an inert
gas to this reaction.
So we're going to add an
inert gas to a container,
increasing the total pressure
at constant temperature.
Why don't you predict
what's going to happen?
All right, 10 more seconds.
Yes, this is a tricky one.
Since it's a clicker
competition, we won't repoll,
and we'll put up the answer.
Ooh, by a slight edge.
So this seems very
counter-intuitive, so let's
discuss it.
So nothing happens.
But why?
So Q depends on the partial
pressure of these gases.
And under the scenario
described here,
the partial pressures were
actually not changing.
So Q was not changing.
And therefore,
there was no shift.
So to understand this, we have
to do a little partial pressure
review.
So partial pressure of gases.
The partial pressure
is the pressure
that each gas would exert
if it were by itself.
That's the definition
of partial pressure.
So if we have oxygen at
one atmosphere and nitrogen
at one atmosphere, and
you add them together,
and now you have a total
pressure of two atmospheres-- 1
plus 1 equals 2-- but the
partial pressure of O2
here is identical to
its partial pressure
here, its partial pressure
as if it was there by itself.
It has no interest
in this inert gas.
It ignores it and feels no
different as a result of it.
Very just sort of isolationist
with these ideal gases.
So the partial pressure
of O2 here is the same.
And so we can look
mathematically
at this expression.
So the partial
pressure of gas A is
equal to the number of moles
of that gas, RT over volume.
The total pressure is equal
to the partial pressure
of gas ABC, how many
ever gases there are.
But the partial pressure
of each gas, like O2 here,
just depends on the number
of moles of that gas
and the volume of
that container,
assuming constant temperature.
So if the partial
pressure isn't going
to change-- so if you add
inert gases, increasing
the total pressure, the
partial pressure is unchanged.
And when the partial pressure
is unchanged, Q is unchanged.
Remember, Q equals
the partial pressure
of the gas products over the
partial pressure or the gas
reactants.
So if partial pressures don't
change, Q does not change.
And if Q doesn't change,
then Q is the same as K,
and there is no shift.
So we have to always
ask ourselves,
what's happened
to the container?
What's the partial pressure?
Did the partial pressure change?
Let's try another example.
Let's add another inert gas.
But this time, we're going
to add it to a container.
And the total pressure
and the temperature
are kept constant in this case.
So this is another
clicker question.
Why didn't you see what you
think is going to happen here?
All right, let's
do 10 more seconds.
All right.
This is a good clicker day.
Sometimes whenever the
answers are all 90%,
then it's decided that these
questions will determine it.
All right, so
let's look at this.
So we're going to
shift toward reactant.
Again, let's consider why.
All right.
So in this problem,
we're adding inert gas.
Total pressure and
temperature are constant.
Well, temperature
was constant before.
But total pressure wasn't
in the last example.
So let's go back to
our picture here.
So if the total pressure
was to stay constant--
and normally, if you
add, one atmosphere of O2
and one atmosphere of
N2, the total pressure
is two atmospheres,
because total pressure
equals partial
pressure of one gas
plus the partial pressure
of the other gas.
So if the total pressure is
constant, what has to happen?
Tell me.
What happened?
So the volume must have changed.
So if the temperature
stayed the same,
the volume of the container
must have increased.
Because otherwise, the
pressure, the total pressure,
should have changed.
And it didn't.
So the system was manipulated.
The volume must have increased.
So now, let's think
about what happens
when the volume increases.
When the volume increases, the
partial pressures decrease,
because they're now
in a bigger volume,
because partial pressure
depends on number of moles.
It depends on volume at
constant temperature.
And so if the partial
pressures decrease,
then Q is also going to change.
And when Q changes, the
reaction is going to respond.
And in this way, it's going
to respond in such a way
that you want to
increase the pressure,
because we have this decrease.
So now we want to increase.
And so we're going to
switch from one mole to two.
And so the reaction is going
to shift toward the reactants.
So in doing these problems with
partial pressures and gases,
you always have to ask
yourself, did Q change?
And whether Q changed is whether
the partial pressures change.
And partial pressure
will definitely
change if you change moles
or if you change the volume.
So often in these
problems, you're saying,
did the volume change?
Volume change, partial
pressure change.
Q is different.
The reaction is going to shift.
So there's lots of examples
on this in problem set 6.
So you can go work on those.
All right.
So that is about volume.
We've had temperature constant.
Can't do that forever.
Now it's time to
change the temperature.
All right.
So changing the temperature
of an equilibrium mixture
by adding heat is going to
shift the reaction in such a way
that some of that
heat is absorbed.
So again, this is consistent
with Le Chatelier.
Minimize the stress.
Add heat, absorb heat.
Remove heat, create more heat.
Again, you're minimizing
the stress to the system.
So now let's think of
different types of reactions.
We have endothermic and
exothermic reactions.
And let's think about the effect
of changing the temperature
on those reactions.
So let's think about
raising the temperature
of an exothermic reaction.
Is that going to
shift the formation
of reactants or products?
What do you think?
Reactants.
All right, let's consider why.
So for an exothermic
reaction, that
means that the reaction
in the forward direction
is exothermic, which also
means that the reaction
in the reverse direction
is endothermic.
So for an exothermic
reaction-- exothermic
in the forward
direction-- heat is
produced when you go from
reactants to products.
And in the endothermic
direction, heat is absorbed.
So if you raise the
temperature, you're
going to want to
minimize the stress.
So you want to shift it in
the endothermic direction.
You want to shift
it in the direction
that heat is absorbed, which, in
this case, is toward reactants.
Now let's think about
an endothermic reaction.
Raising the temperature
of an endothermic reaction
is going to shift
toward products.
And if we put our
pictures again,
an endothermic
reaction is endothermic
in the forward direction.
So heat is absorbed from
reactants to products.
And in the reverse direction
of an endothermic reaction
is the exothermic direction
in which heat is produced.
So if you raise the
temperature, then you're
going to want to shift
in such a direction
to minimize that
stress in a direction
to absorb heat,
which, in this case,
sends you toward products.
So here, the predictive
tool is our friend delta H.
So delta H tells us
whether reactions
are exothermic or endothermic,
whether delta h is
negative or positive.
So for some things,
the prediction
is what's happening
to delta G. Here,
our predictive tool is
the sine of delta H.
So let's do a clicker
question, and tell me
what direction you think
this particular reaction is
going to go if you add heat.
All right, 10 more seconds.
All right.
So is this an exo- or
endothermic reaction?
Exothermic, because we
have the negative sign.
And so then we can think
about what's going to happen.
So you add heat.
You're going to want to
shift it in the direction
to absorb the heat.
So you're going to shift
it toward reactants
in the endothermic
direction, absorb the heat.
So again, delta H is
the predictive tool.
You have to remember
negative delta H exothermic,
positive delta H endothermic.
And then just think
about shifting
to minimize the stress,
always minimizing the stress.
All right.
So our equilibrium constant K.
It's a constant, except that it
changes with temperature.
So the equilibrium constant
has a temperature dependence.
So big K, the
equilibrium constant,
can change with temperature.
Reaction rates can also
change with temperature.
So when we talk
about kinetics, we're
going to have little Ks,
which are reaction rates.
And they're going to change
with temperature as well.
So how does the
equilibrium constant
change with temperature?
And you might feel a
derivation coming on,
and you would be right.
So let's think about what we
know, equations that involve
the equilibrium constant.
We saw before that
delta G0 equals minus RT
natural log of K.
What else do we
know about delta G0 equations?
What else does delta G0 equal?
It equals our friend delta
H not minus T delta S0.
And we can rearrange
this expression,
solving for the
natural log of K.
And if we assume-- and
it's a good assumption--
that delta H and delta S0 are
independent of temperature,
that means that K is going
to change with temperature.
And we can think about
two different temperatures
and come up with a
unified equation.
So if we consider a reaction
carried out-- temperature T1
and temperature T2-- we would
have natural log of K2 equals
minus delta H0 over R
and over temperature 2
plus delta S over R. And
we have the same thing now
but for equilibrium constant
1 and temperature 1.
So we can combine these,
and things will cancel.
So subtracting those two
equations gives you this.
And it's a named
equation in chemistry,
which means that it's probably
pretty important, because a lot
of things don't have names.
So we have the natural
log of the equilibrium
constant K2 over
equilibrium constant K1
equals minus delta
H0 over R, which
is a constant, in brackets,
1 over temperature 2 minus 1
over temperature 1.
Van 't Hoff equation.
And later in the
semester, I'm going
to ask you to recall
this equation.
And I'll have a special prize
for the first person who
comes up with the Van
't Hoff equation, so you
can keep that in mind.
I think it's a lecture 34.
So we have a ways to go.
All right.
So let's think about
what is true, then,
if delta H0 is less than 0.
First of all, is that
exothermic or endothermic?
Exothermic.
All right.
So now we're going to
think about increasing
the temperature of an
exothermic reaction.
So temperature 2 is going to
be greater than temperature 1.
And we already thought about
what was going to happen.
But let's make sure this
equation is valid and works
for what we just saw.
So if we increase
the temperature here,
what's true about this equation?
Well, what's true is you
have a minus sign here.
Delta H is negative
for exothermic.
And if your temperature 2 is
greater than temperature 1,
that's also a negative.
So overall, you're going
to have a negative value.
And if you have a
negative value here,
that's going to mean that
K1 is greater than K2,
which means that, at
your new equilibrium,
there'll be fewer products.
All right.
Well, this works with what
we were just talking about.
If you increase the temperature
of an exothermic reaction,
it shifts it toward
reactants to absorb the heat.
So there would be less products.
We've shifted toward reactants.
So you can just
think about what's
happening and moving
in the direction
to minimize the stress.
And you can also
look at the equation
and mathematically
figure out what's
going to be true about
the equilibrium constants.
It's great to have
a backup plan.
All right.
So if we decrease
the temperature,
T2 is less than T1.
So now we have our minus.
We have a minus.
But now this is a plus term.
And so that's going to mean
our K1 is less than K2.
We have more products here.
So if we decrease
the temperature
of an exothermic reaction, the
reaction responds in such a way
to minimize the
stress, add more heat.
So you switch to the
exothermic direction.
And so you should
have more products
at this new equilibrium.
All right.
So now, why don't
you tell me what
should happen for
the scenario where
delta H0 is greater than 0?
Which of the following
should be true?
All right, 10 more seconds.
Yeah, so most people are
right in that-- yeah.
I think this is a
good example of how,
when things are
expressed different ways,
sometimes it's hard
to see that it all
is consistent with each other.
So yeah, all of those
turn out to be true.
All right, so let's
look at it over here.
So this is an
endothermic reaction.
When we increase the temperature
of an endothermic reaction,
you still have this minus sign.
But now this is plus.
But when we've increased the
temperature, this is minus.
So you get an overall
plus in signs, which
means that K1 is less than K2.
Increasing the temperature
of an endothermic reaction
shifts it toward products.
If we decrease the temperature,
the net sign is negative here.
So K1 is going to
be greater than K2.
We decrease the temperature.
It shifts in the exothermic
backwards direction,
and we have less products.
All right.
So K changes with temperature.
You can see this equation
on your equation sheet
or just think about
minimizing the stress.
So what is this useful for?
Well, figuring out
how to maximize
the yield of a reaction can
be very important in industry.
One process that is an
important industrial process
is the Haber-Bosch
process, where
you take nitrogen gas and
hydrogen gas and make ammonia.
This process, which was
developed a long time ago,
is still used today.
And each year, you
make 1.6 times 10
to the 10th
kilograms of ammonia,
which you use for
fertilizer and other things.
You know what other
things ammonia is often
used for besides fertilizer?
Explosives, yeah.
So if you look at the dates
of these process development
and the names of these
people, they're German.
And so we have World
War I and World War II.
I'm thinking that the push
to come up with this process
was probably not for fertilizer
and the farmers at this time.
This was an important
part of the war effort,
to get this process to
work to make explosives.
So Haber over here
also is considered
the father of chemical weapons.
He came up with gases,
such as phosgene.
And he would study the effects
of how they killed people.
And one of the ironies
is that he was Jewish.
And so a lot of his discoveries
were used and resulted
in his relatives dying.
So he was an interesting
figure in history.
Carl Bosch, on the other hand,
disapproved strongly of Hitler
and was fired from his post.
He didn't lose his life,
but his career was ended.
But he still had his Nobel
Prize, so maybe it was OK.
So this is an interesting
little history about chemistry.
But this process
is still used now.
No one has come up
with anything better.
And we could think about,
what are the challenges
of making this reaction go?
So it's an exothermic reaction.
So what temperature
would you want
to use to get more products?
Right, you want to
use low temperature,
because that would
favor your products.
But low temperature is
also sometimes not great,
because it slows the
rate, which is bad.
So the compromise temperature
that's used in this process
is 500 degrees Celsius.
So it's pretty hot.
So this works, again, maximizing
the yield of products.
So what are other ways to
drive this toward products?
So can someone suggest
another way [INAUDIBLE]?
I don't think I have
two [INAUDIBLE].
If you have your
parents here, they
might want this lovely
residential water bottle.
[LAUGHTER]
What are other ways to
drive this toward products?
Maybe someone could
run the mic up there.
Is this-- yeah, it's gone.
You could decrease the volume?
Yep.
Yes!
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[CHEERING]
So there's a couple
things that you can do.
One is you compress the volume.
And the reason why
this works is that,
if you note you have four
molecules over here-- 1
plus 3 going to 2.
So if you compress
that volume down,
you're going to shift it toward
the fewer number of molecules,
which is 2.
So that shifts it
toward products.
The other thing that they do is
they actually remove products
from the reaction.
So they liquefy out the
product at some point.
And when you remove
the product, that also
shifts the reaction
toward more products
to minimize the stress.
So these are two of the
things that are done.
So you have to
have high pressure
to compress that volume
down and high temperatures.
So this process costs
a lot of energy.
So we spend a lot of
energy in this country
doing this reaction.
And the reason why
is because it's
really hard to split
nitrogen. So what kind of bond
does nitrogen have, N2 have?
Triple bond, right.
It's very hard.
It has a high bond order.
It's very hard to
break that bond.
And so you really have
to work at breaking it.
So if you're doing
industry, there's
lots of nitrogen in the air.
So a lot of it is available.
But it's just very hard to
utilize it to fix that nitrogen
into another form.
So lots of nitrogen in the air.
Nitrogen is needed
by all living things,
but it's really hard to
break that triple bond.
But if you're a bacteria, you
have a much easier time doing
this than if you are a person.
And bacteria have an
enzyme called nitrogenase.
Adding the "-ase"
means it's an enzyme.
So this is an enzyme
that works on nitrogen.
Most people call it
"nit-raw-genase,"
but it's really "nitrogen-ace."
And it splits nitrogen.
And it does this by these
really complex metallocofactors.
Lots of metals in here.
You have iron and molybdenum.
You also have inorganic sulfur.
And it's those d-orbitals
that let you do this.
So you can use high
temperatures, high pressure.
Or you can get a transition
metal with beautiful d-orbitals
to do your work for you.
And a lot of people
are trying to come up
with their own catalyst inspired
by nature to get this to work.
So this is an ongoing
area of research.
And I just want to mention one
of the leaders in the field.
This is a husband-and-wife
team, actually.
And Markus Ribbe is a
German with a very heavy
German accent.
And so Germans have been
dominating this nitrogen fixing
field for a very long time.
But Markus Ribbe is like the
nicest person you would ever
meet in your entire life.
And he's trying to figure out
environmentally friendly ways
to do it.
So again, chemistry
is a powerful tool
to change the world.
But let's change it
for the better, please,
and try to come up with ways
to protect our environment.
All right, so there's
one application
of Le Chatelier's
principle, maximizing
the yield of a reaction.
Another example comes in
medicine and Le Chatelier's
principle with respect to
another metalloprotein,
which is hemoglobin.
So hemoglobin has a "heme,"
which is iron, more d-orbitals.
If I'm this excited now, wait
till I get to d-orbitals.
It's very exciting.
I can't wait.
I love transition metals.
So anyway, so we
have hemoglobin.
So hemoglobin Hb plus
oxygen yields oxyhemoglobin.
It's hemoglobin
with oxygen bound.
And this is an incredibly
important reaction,
because otherwise your air,
your O2, would be in your lungs
and wouldn't leave.
But hemoglobin carries
it to the body, where
it can be used to make energy.
So we really need the reaction.
We want to maximize the
product of that reaction.
So this disequilibrium
can be shifted
if you have less O2 around, a
lower partial pressure of O2.
And this can happen as
you go up in altitude.
The pressure of
oxygen decreases,
and that's a real problem.
So any of you real
serious mountain climbers?
At least one.
How about somewhat
serious, climbed
a mountain, maybe worried
about your hemoglobin
levels, altitude thickness?
A few, OK.
So what can happen
here is, when you have,
again, lower pressure,
then the reaction
shifts in the
opposite direction.
It's like you have a
lower amount of reactant,
so you shift to
make more reactant.
And this is what happens.
You have less
oxygenated hemoglobin,
and that can make
you pretty sick.
So for some of you
if you want to say,
what can you do about this?
How can you shift the
reaction back the other way?
Do you know what your body does?
Your body is very clever.
What does it do?
Yeah, so it makes
it more hemoglobin.
So that's why you need to
give your body a little time
to adjust.
Can't do it immediately.
You have to give it a little
time to make more protein.
But when you increase
the amount of reactant,
it'll shift toward product.
So when you increase
the reactants
to minimize the stress, it
shifts to make more products.
So this is how the
body compensates.
So I'm going to tell
you very briefly
about significant
figures, and then I'm
going to have time to
show you a Mole Day video.
And it's actually
from UC Irvine,
where Markus Ribbe is from.
So today, we're celebrating UC
Irvine chemistry department.
Anyway, I just want to
mention significant figures.
I have a confession to make.
I didn't know the rules
of significant figures
for logs when I started
teaching this course.
And this will be
information that I
think now I'll have to purge
from my brain on my deathbed.
But pay attention
to these, and we'll
have some clicker
questions on them.
So that'll be fun.
OK.
So let's look at these two--
log of two different numbers.
Note the 3 here is
the 3 over here.
The 23, 10 to the 23-- 10 to the
23, Mole Day-- is the 23 here.
But those are not significant.
That 3 and that 23 are
not significant figures.
These are the significant
figures-- 7.310.
So there are four
significant figures here.
Those four significant figures
end up after the decimal point.
So those are the
significant figures
after the decimal point.
And if you go the other
direction, if you have a 0.389
here, that has three
significant figures.
So three significant
figures here.
But if you have
12.389, you still
have three significant figures,
because that 12 ends up
over here.
All right.
With that, give it a try.
This could be for the clicker
championship of today.
All right.
Let's just do 10 more seconds.
Should I show my
video first, or do you
want to do the winner first?
Do winner first.
Winner first, OK.
All right.
OK, so 3 after
the decimal place.
And let's look at the
winner, and then we're
going to end with a short video.
Oh, man!
All right.
Dan, whoa.
OK.
All right, so we're going
to end with a short video.
And here it is.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - "LET IT GO"]
- (SINGING) Snow looks white,
'cause it's scattering light
elastically.
Atoms are everywhere I
look, though none of them
can be seen.
Molecules have always been
a challenge to resolve.
Light microscopes don't work.
Heavens knows we tried.
Do they exist?
Can they been seen?
Maybe using some spectroscopy!
For centuries, we didn't know.
Well, now we know!
Chemists know,
chemists know what
makes water freeze and flow.
Chemists know, chemists
know why fireflies can glow.
All chemists know
Avogadro order 10 to 23.
The moles never
bothered me anyway.
Angstroms measure distance,
nomenclature hard to say.
Though we are macroscopic,
we always find a way!
We love to see what we
can do, synthesizing
novel molecules from Exclusion
Principle of Pauli-- chemistry!
Chemists know, chemists
know about ozone in the sky.
Chemists know, chemists know
sigma bonding versus pi.
We understand Le Chatelier.
Equilibrium!
There's chemistry to be
found from the air down
to the ground.
We make these compounds
form in flasks
with bottoms that are round.
We hope they crystallize,
'cause columns are the worst.
Still we strive to do all this
for the chance to be the first!
Chemists know, chemists know why
it's red at the break of dawn.
Chemists know,
chemists know where
reactants go when they're gone.
We need to know every single
way to form or break bonds!
The moles never
bothered me anyway.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
All right, have a great weekend.
Please return any
borrowed clickers.